the film opens up in June 1865 in
Missouri with a group of comrades who
serve for the Union Army they travel on
Horseback to a farm owned by a guy named
Jamie Hedges the comrades delivered
tragic news of Jamie's elder brother
Josiah who also served in the Union Army
saying that he is no more Jaime is
deeply hurt by the news but he
appreciates the comrade's effort to
personally come all the way just to
inform him of the loss however one of
the comrades named harknet reveals that
there is another reason for their visit
he claims that Josiah owed him a
significant debt of 500 before he died
so harknet demands their ancestral Jewel
box as compensation this demand angers
Jaime and he vehemently rejects their
request amidst the escalating tension
Jaime's dog continues to bark at the
comrades leading another member named
Little Bill to heartlessly shoot the dog
this devastates Jaime and he breaks down
in tears however harknet who is not
interested in such an emotional scene
man handles him and demands to know the
whereabouts of the jewel box when Jaime
still refuses to comply Harkness shoots
a warning bullet through his leg despite
being injured Jaime manages to crawl
away retrieve his pistol and Fires at
Little Bill sadly the bullet strikes a
metal alcohol can in little Bill's
pocket sparing him from harm in
retaliation heart net shoots Jamie's
other leg causing him to suffer
excruciating pain following this he
instructs the rest of the fellow
soldiers to break into The Farmhouse and
find the jewel box as evening Falls
Josiah also known as Edge who happens to
be still alive arrives at The Farmhouse
and is devastated to witness his younger
brother being hanged to death this fills
him with intense rage and he vows to
seek Vengeance the scene then shifts to
Kansas two months later where Edge
arrives in the town of Seward governed
by the sheriff known as Big Bill Edge
enters the town carrying his rifle and
Witnesses a Gallows where a resident is
about to be executed by hanging upon
seeing Edge armed one of Big Bill's
henchmen named Deputy Trickett
approaches him and demands that he hand
over his rifle Edge refuses to comply
leading Deputy Trickett to point his gun
at him amidst this intense confrontation
the hanging is carried out is ordered by
the sheriff just then Edge retaliates by
engaging in a fight with the henchmen
and then precisely shooting the Rope
saving The Condemned man's life
surprisingly instead of getting angry
Big Bill is impressed by Edge's weapon
accuracy and proposes that he become his
new Deputy Edge accepts the offer seeing
it as an opportunity to remain in the
town and track down the former comrades
responsible for his brother's death
later on Deputy Trickett gives him a
tour of the town where Edge notices
children playing with a toy gun this
reminds him of the beautiful times when
he used to teach Jaime how to handle a
gun oh America a short while later a
resident named Benny who appears to be a
talented artist offers to guide Edge to
his room once there Edge tosses his
belongings on the bed and Benny spots
the same metal can with a bullet hole
that belonged to Little Bill from
earlier curious Benny asks about its
purpose and Edge responds that he is
searching for the owner of the can in
the evening edges seen on the roof
gazing at the town and silently vowing
to avenge his brother's death afterwards
he goes to a local bar where he engages
in conversation with Deputy Trickett he
inquires about the reason behind the
earlier death penalty to which Deputy
Trickett explains that the man was seen
spitting in front of the sheriff during
their talk Edge notices a picture of Big
Bill with a boy and asks about the
child's identity Deputy Trickett informs
him that the boy is Little Bill the son
of Big Bill shortly after little Bill's
wife Pilar enters the bar and everyone
inside seems to be captivated by her
beauty she joins a group of men who are
playing cards just then a black dog
enters the scene and wanders around one
of the men who responds by cruelly
kicking the dog away this act infuriates
Edge as he remembers how his dog was
brutally killed some months ago so he
confronts the group and punishes them
the same night Edge seeks out Benny and
inquires about little Bill's whereabouts
although hesitant at first Benny
eventually reveals the location of
little Bill's house prompting Edge to
make his way there he stealthily enters
the house through a window and
cautiously approaches the bedroom only
to find Pilar with padlocked Underpants
before long big Bill appears from behind
claiming that he knows Edge's intentions
he then offers Edge the key to pilar's
Underpants and asks him to sleep with
her but the latter strictly refuses
stating that it is not his style he's
not here to [__] he's here to kill
following this the sheriff walks him out
of the bedroom in order to have some
private conversation he proposes a deal
he will promote Edge to a higher
position if he forgives whatever
transgression Little Bill committed
against him in the past but before Edge
response their conversation is
interrupted by a loud gunshot prompting
them to rush outside to check as big
Bell and his men pursue the source of
the gunshot Pilar pulls Edge to a corner
and reveals that she orchestrated The
Gunshot with Benny's help in order to
create an opportunity for a private
conversation she implores Edge to assist
her in escaping the town far away from
Big Bill and his son when Edge declines
she discloses the existence of a
substantial amount of gold hidden
somewhere nearby the church this seems
to be a secret that big bill has been
searching for for years Pilar suggests
that they retrieve the gold and run away
from the town together before parting
ways she discreetly places a key in
Edge's pocket urging him to consider her
offer wisely not long after a Big Bill
returns with his son and driven by anger
Edge contemplates attacking him
immediately however he is captured by
the henchmen and confined to a prison
cell at midnight when the guards are
asleep Edge uses the same key provided
by Pilar to unlock the cell door he then
swiftly kills the guard before heading
towards Pilar there he inquires why she
hates Big Bill so much in response she
shockingly reveals that the sheriff has
forced himself onto her in the past and
he is now looking to shift the blame
onto others after this they resume their
discussion about the hidden gold and
decide to seek information from Benny as
his father was the one who melted the
gold before hiding it he year it is
revealed that Benny's father was a
blacksmith and one day while working
young Benny accidentally placed his hand
in extreme flame causing it to detach
from the body and turn into precious
gold the following day Big Bill enters
the town prison only to discover that
edge has already escaped in addition he
finds a note on the table instructing
him to send Little Bill to a particular
cliff in the next scene we see Edge and
Benny waiting at the designated Cliff
when the sheriff arrives with his
henchmen before Edge can react some
henchmen restrain him and subject him to
a brutal and merciless beating meanwhile
the sheriff who is now aware of the gold
has Benny apprehended in the middle of
this commotion Edge manages to seize a
gun from one of the henchmen's pockets
shoots several of them and then leaps
off the cliff unfortunately he lands on
a tree with a sharp Branch piercing
through his abdomen while suffering from
immense pain Little Bill shows up on top
of the cliff and discloses that it was
harknet who killed Jaime as soon as
Little Bill departs Edge summons all his
strengths to pull out the impaled tree
branch from his body and jumps into the
river below he then swims to the shore
and finds shelter in an abandoned house
where he applies herbal medicine to his
wounds by himself after some rest Edge
Ventures back to the town determined to
take revenge he first breaks into the
Sheriff's Office and acquires some guns
including a traditional machine gun on
the other hand Big Bill ties up Benny
and forces him to Spill the location of
the hidden gold the innocent guy
hesitates prompting the sheriff to
threaten him with torture at the same
time harknet and his comrade group show
up upon seeing their rifles Big Bill
reminds them of the town's rule to
surrender their weapons before entering
Seward however their conversation is
abruptly interrupted when they notice a
bomb in the air realizing the imminent
danger everyone becomes scared and seeks
cover soon the bomb detonates and as the
dust settles they see Edge positioned
behind the machine gun without any delay
he opens fire killing several guards and
inciting a riot at one point harknot
almost shoots Edge but the restrained
Benny distracts him unfortunately
because of this act he is shot and
killed as the conflict continues harknet
runs inside the sheriff's home and holds
Pilar hostage because of this Edge is
forced to lower his weapons and comply
with heart Net's order at the same time
Big Bill shoots him from the top of the
building causing the bullet to pierce
his shoulder but despite the injury Edge
manages to grab a bomb and throw it
towards Big Bill in a state of panic the
latter gets entangled in a rope and
falls off the building leaving him
hanging by his leg Big Bill tries to
shoot the Rope to free himself but he is
unable to aim it in the process he
accidentally hits a large Bell revealing
a stash of gold hidden beneath it
delighted he shoots at the Gold several
times however his Joy is short-lived
because the same black dog from earlier
picks up the about to explode bomb and
hurls it towards Big Bill
ultimately leading to his demise
meanwhile harknet takes advantage of
this distraction and escapes on his
horse an injured Edge attempts to aim at
him but harknet is already out of range
determined to exact Vengeance Edge
mounts another horse and pursues the bad
guy pushing aside the pain from his
injury but unfortunately he collapses
Midway and loses track of harknet
shortly afterward a woman named Beth
comes to his Aid and helps him tend to
his wounds turns out that Beth is a
detective from another town and she has
been monitoring Seward for several
months after a while Edge regains his
Consciousness and returns back to the
town to execute Little Bill meanwhile
Little Bill who is overwhelmed by the
fear of edge thinks of committing The
Unthinkable by hanging himself however
Edge arrives at The Gallows just in time
and shoots him multiple times before
subjecting him to a brutal death by
hanging in the final scene we see
harknet back in Missouri there he
attends a gathering and addresses a
group of elderly Rich folk he raises
concerns about the rising influence of
colored people viewing it as distressing
news for their state furthermore harknet
proposes the idea of creating a new and
systematic uprising of the former
Confederate State when the elderly folks
refused to comply a sadistic and
deranged harknet threatens them by
shooting a couple of workers the movie
ends here abruptly subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching